한 주만에 뵙습니다. 여러분의 말벗, 말벗입니다.
촬영하는 오늘이 화요일입니다. 서울에 첫눈이 내렸습니다.
첫눈, 아주 설레네요. 너무 좋아요.
헛소리 그만하고 빨리 본론으로 가도록 하겠습니다.
시청자 여러분들의 사연을 통해서 만들어지는 말벗스 채널, 오늘의 사연은요.
말하기를 할 때 상대방의 말을 듣고 내가 말을 받아쳐야 되는 상황에서
뭔가 할 말을 잃어버리고 당황해서 할 말이 생각이 나지 않는
그래서 순발력을 요하는 분들을 위해서 준비한 영상입니다.
오늘 영상도 끝까지 시청해 주시기 바랍니다.
오늘 영상 도움되셨습니다.
여러분의 말벗, 말벗습니다.
오늘 주제 많은 분들이 공감하실 거라고 생각이 듭니다.
대화를 할 때 상대의 말하기와 함께 나의 말하기를 이어가야 되는 상황에서
할 말이 갑자기 생각이 안 나고 당황해서 멈칫하거나
당황하게 되는 그런 경험들 한 번 이상 해보셨을 거라고 생각이 들어요.
이런 상황에서 과연 어떻게 말하기 연습을 해야 말하기가 늘 수가 있을지
순발력 있는 말하기 하는 방법에 대해서 오늘 원포인트 알려드리도록 할게요.
그 연습 방법은 바로 정해진 답을 만들어라입니다.
말하기란 그런 것 같습니다.
말하기가 내 예상과 벗어난 예측 불가한 그러한 상황에 놓여져 있다면
누구나 그 말하기를 할 수 있습니다.
말하기에 있어서는 어려울 수 있어요.
완벽한 말하기를 구사하기는 어려울 수 있다는 거죠.
그래서 우리는 꼭 기억해야 됩니다.
내가 이 상황에 맞게 어떠한 멘트가 준비가 되어 있다면
그리고 그것이 나의 생각으로 비롯된
그리고 그것을 정립해 놓은 것이라면
더욱더 말하기를 수월하게 할 수가 있겠죠.
그래서 제가 알려드리는 방법은요.
바로 바로 바로 상황에 맞는 멘트를 적어 놓는 겁니다.
굳이 내가 말하는 것을 적어 놓고
대본으로 만들 필요까지야.
그리고 이렇게 말하게 되면 너무 기계적으로 말하는 것 같지 않을까요?
아닙니다.
대본을 그대로 읽으시라는 게 아니고요.
내가 한 번쯤이라도 나의 생각을 정립할 수 있는
정리해 놓을 수 있는 기회를 주라는 거죠.
언젠가 여러분들 그런 생각해 본 적 없으세요?
말을 하다 보면
내가 이 상황에서 이렇게 얘기했으면 더 좋았을 텐데
하고 뒤늦게 후회를 하시잖아요.
그런 후회를 할 것을 미리 예습을 해보는 겁니다.
미리 생각을 해보는 것이고
그 생각을 정리해 놓는 거예요.
한 번쯤이라도 생각을 정리해 놨던 것들은
자연스럽게 말로서 풀어낼 수 있거든요.
하지만 한 번도 생각해 보지 못한 것
그런 것들이 갑작스럽게 그 상황이 나한테 훅 들어왔을 때는
나도 할 말이 없어진다는 거죠.
그래서 내가 자주 처해지는 안 좋았던 상황들
그런 상황들에 맞게
이 상황이라면 나는 이런 말을 했으면 좋았겠다
라는 걸 한번 직접 써보세요.
그 주제들에 대해서 조금 더 재미있게 한번 풀어보기도 하고
또 진지하게 한번 나의 생각을 적어보기도 하고
또 나의 진짜 그냥 진심 어린 생각을 적어보기도 하면서
나의 생각을 정리하는 시간을 꼭 한번 가져보시길 바랄게요.
제가 이런 말을 당당하게 여러분께 할 수 있는 이유는
제가 일전에도 한번 소개해드렸던 것처럼
저는 돌잔치 사회에 일을 했었어요.
그렇게 사회자 MC 일을 시작을 하게 됐거든요.
거의 5, 6년 정도를 굉장히 긴 시간을 사회를 봤습니다.
5년 정도를 사회에 일을 했었거든요.
5년 차, 6년 차가 됐을 때쯤은요.
이런 생각이 듭니다.
내가 이 멘트를 굉장히 많이 해왔었기 때문에
어느 순간 멘트를 하면서 다른 생각을 할 수가 있어요.
아니 그러면 그 행사에 집중을 안 하는 거 아닌가요?
집중합니다.
집중을 하고 있는데도 다른 생각을 할 수 있는 여유가 생겨요.
왜냐하면 내가 지금껏 많이 생각해왔었고
많이 행했었던 그런 말하기들이기 때문에
나한테는 너무나도 입에 착착 붙어있는 그런 말하기이기 때문이죠.
그래서 그 와중에 상황에 따라서
다른 나의 다른 생각 그리고 그 생각을 통해서
애드리브를 자연스럽게 풀 수 있는 그런 여유가 생긴다는 겁니다.
정해진 답 그리고 그 정해진 답으로
나에게 익숙한 말하기가 나의 입에서 웸둔다면
나는 그 이후의 상황에 대해서도
조금 더 애드리브로 순발력 있게 이야기할 수 있는
여유를 가질 수 있다는 겁니다.
이 말을 꼭 기억해 주시기 바랍니다.
말하기는 결국 나의 생각을 얼마만큼 정리해봤고
그리고 그것을 말로 행해봤는가가 가장 중요하다는 것입니다.
꼭 기억해 주시길 바랍니다.
여기까지 오늘 영상은 여기까지입니다.
이뿐만이 아니라 순발력 있게 이야기할 수 있는 방법
조금 더 조리있게 바로바로 즉흥적으로 이야기할 수 있는 방법에 대해서는
이후에 영상을 또 제작하도록 할게요.
일단 오늘 제가 알려드린 정해진 답변을 만드는 방법부터
한번 실천에 옮겨주시길 바라겠습니다.
오늘 영상 역시 마찬가지로 도움되셨다면
좋아요와 댓글도 많이 많이 부탁드릴게요.
구독도 잊지 마시길 바라겠고요.
저는 지금까지 여러분의 말벗 말버스였습니다.